dans le langage parlementaire on appelle
ça une session d'orientation pour les
élus il y en a eu plusieurs
de l'endroit où se trouvent les bureaux
et les toilettes des règles qui
régissent la chambre des communes au
code de conduite des députés c'est
l'apprentissage avant la grande rentrée
parlementaire
moi j'étais enseignant durant de
nombreuses années et dont j'ai
l'habitude d'être en avant puis de
donner des leçons
maintenant je suis sur les bancs d'école
et c'est moi qui reçoit plein de son
professeur économiste auteur jean yves
duclos et le nouveau ministre de la
famille des enfants et du développement
social
au nombre de ces dossiers les
allocations pour les familles un défi
surtout pour quelqu'un qui n'a jamais
siégé au parlement canadien
tout comme son collègue de calgary quand
le ministre des anciens combattants de
nouveaux visages dit il des idées
fraîches blessé par une balle confiné à
son fauteuil roulant depuis plus de 20
ans cet avocat albertain devra gérer le
dossier des suicides chez les soldats
technique les néophytes sont nombreux
comme mariam moncef à peine 30 ans la
ministre des institutions démocratiques
qui devra gérer l la réforme électorale
et la réforme du sénat
aino dallas à haining preuve je sais que
j'ai beaucoup à apprendre dit elle est
toute une mission devant moi une vie
déjà bien remplie à l'âge de 10 ans elle
a fui son afghanistan natal et les
talibans avec sa mère et ses deux jeunes
soeurs un long périple qui les a menés
de kaboul à peterborough en ontario
wasn't à pfizer et wyeth a connu un
voyage de plusieurs mois l'ont
périlleuse et désagréable dit elle une
ancienne réfugiée bien placé pour faire
sa part maintenant dans le dossier des
réfugiés syriens
et à ceux qui ont peur de les accueillir
elle dit ceci d un script de the
darkness ces réfugiés fuient la terreur
il ne la porte pas avec eux
il y à 197 nouveaux députés sur 338 à la
chambre des communes qui commenceront à
siéger dès cette semaine
fini les sessions d'orientation et les
répétitions générales
ce qu'ils n'ont pas encore acquis ils
devront apprendre sur le tas ici joyce
n'avait pu radio canada ottawa